I gotta tell ya some people when they
expect a storm they bring an umbrella
some come dress prepared and we're going
to bring out the cast that are truly
prepared this I think last year we saw
Gotham debut in this hall and it was
astounding now we've seen the season
which is blown people away and now we're
going to see season two so are you guys
ready to welcome some of the citizens of
Gotham you know I don't think they heard
you that time I think we need again so
let me please have the pleasure to
introduce the cat creatives and cast of
Fox's Gotham first of all the executive
producer mr. Bruno Heller it's like the
Long Walk all right we're going to do
everyone quick also executive producer
mr. Danny cannon you know him is
detective Jim Gordon and you're going to
know a lot more this season mr. Ben
McKenzie please welcome miss Myrna
Bracken hello
and of course detective Gordon's partner
of a sort mr. donello you know if we're
going to talk about umbrellas we might
as well bring out the man himself mr.
Robin Lord Taylor
mr. Sean Pertwee otherwise known as
Alfred Celia
Carmen become hello Cameron and of
course the young mr. Bruce David she's
here
Aaron Richards mr. Corey Michael Smith
please welcome also Nikita producer mr.
John Stevens and again mr. Jeff Jones
also executive producer well this I
guess is the mega cast for the mega
panel so I guess we'll start off right
away Bruno we just saw the rise of the
villains so what are we going to see in
season two guys um season 1 was very
much about old school Gotham about um
Gotham in its early days the Mafia but
that old school kind of crime this
season as it says it's the rise of the
villains there's a new breed of villain
crime is getting more theatrical more
grotesque the stories are becoming
larger and more epic as the city starts
to decline into chaos um so this season
is is bigger more colorful more intense
more exciting um more more and more oh
well we have some of the villains of a
sort here on on stage and of course we
have one Vil in particular Selina who
seems to be struggling a little bit
between if she is a villain or not well
that's that's life as a teenager isn't
it yeah it's been a long time for me
brother I don't know uh what does it
been like for you oh it's been great I
love playing the character I I just I
love everything about it and I'm excited
for what's going to happen this season
because she's gonna be trying to figure
out where she stands whether she's a bad
guy or a good guy and we get I get to
see
a big part of her background so I'm
really excited about that Jeff I wanted
to ask you I mean you know the Batman
story is so well stuff I mean I think
besides Sherlock Holmes he's the other
great detective so in many ways --is
what was some of the concerns and
challenges of bringing this I guess
backstory or pre qualms what do we call
it Bruno huh well first off he's better
than Sherlock Holmes oh yes but it
honestly goes back to bruno and what
Bruno's uh vision for Gotham was and I
mean it started with Bruno so really
finding someone you know all these
characters whether it's Batman or
anybody it all starts with the writer
the showrunner and Bruno had a very
specific vision for Gotham so um I never
forget when he pitched that first scene
that Selina witnessed the murder of
Bruce Wayne's parents and that to me
right away I knew that he's got it he's
got a vision he's got a perspective he's
gonna add new things that you don't
think people could add to this mythology
anymore there's more stories till about
Batman than any other character ever
Edie
yeah that's cool and and and you need
someone like Bruno to really give it a
spin and then Danny cannon to to realize
it and look at this amazing cast to uh
to bring their own takes and all these
characters we have dogs barking in
agreement that sounds like Gotham City
out there uh-huh um you know one of the
things of course is we've seen
throughout this season and we saw in the
season finale is if you call season to
the rise of villains another part of his
the rise of Jim Gordon yes um so Ben I
wanted to know for you going coming
through this first season you guys are
now it's a whole new ballgame for you
for both of you guys I suppose the the
the great police of Gotham City that's
right yeah as the villains rise the
there's an arms race and the good guys
have to increase their force as well and
I think there'll be new heroes
introduced on the good guys side and
they'll have to band together and fight
the rise of the villains so it's um it's
pretty exciting time what is it like for
you know the relationship between the
two of you guys was
so vital to kind of establishing the
tone in many ways outside of young
master Bruce and the Baxter we all know
how would you think that relationship
between the two of them has changed now
I think it's um you know grown more
complex the two of them understand each
other better and Harvey has saw Jim a
lot of things about how the city
actually works um I think there's a
mutual respect and I imagine a
partnership for years to come right yeah
I think so it's interesting because I
don't know that much more than the
audience really knows about what's going
down but I kind of I have a feeling that
you know Jim Gordon reinvigorated Harvey
Bullock it kind of woke up this thing
that had been idealistic in him years
ago but at the end of season one with
the kind of rising tide of Anarchy I
think Harvey bullocks just really like I
look right now
old and tired beaten and it really feels
like it's this senseless quixotic task
that you have this tide of just so many
bad things coming and you're just
standing there with spoons in your hand
and you can't fight back so I think you
know I think at this stage when we find
Harvey in season 2 he might be he might
be beaten down he might be a little less
idealistic than Jim Gordon about our
chances to stem the tide of the bad that
is coming Aaron you know this this the
first season saw emphasize a lot from
the very beginning the relationship
between you and Jim but now there's
another woman in Jim's life I wanted to
get a sense from you guys about how that
relationship is and how it's changed my
relationship with Jim oh I you know
pizarra enough I can't hear you down
here ah um oh that's louder than I
thought it's gonna be so I mean the
relationship between me and Jim has
obviously changed quite a lot and
because I killed my parents and he's a
police officer so I yeah it's strange to
say the least
do you think that the way the kept the
character the way that she's developed
do you think that we're gonna see
a more of a change from her or I guess I
maybe I should ask Bruno and Danny what
are we gonna season she's not gonna get
less crazy she no no he's a crazy
ex-girlfriend from hell but she says so
but she also becomes a a woman in full
in her own right it's it's a story of
insanity but it's also a story of
fulfillment and fulfilling your
potential
it's just crazy potential to talk a
little bit about fulfillment let's talk
about Alfred and Bruce hmm you know that
we saw obviously the first season was
really telling from the terrible tragedy
onwards now are we gonna get it more of
a sense of the relationship between them
you know it's not a father-son it's more
like a mentor and a student Sean David
where do you guys see this going I think
you've got to go away with any
relationship to sort of come back and
it's been a sort of tumultuous and bumpy
ride their relationship has been is he's
not his actual father he sort of
inherited the position I think that
you're gonna see in season two um more
of a contract being drawn between them
and you're gonna see him start to Train
I know you're so gonna see Alfred come
out the traps a bit more which I'm
personally delighted about I won't be
making so much cup of tea and things I'm
sorry aren't about a little more so yeah
it's gonna be it's it's gonna be a more
adult relationship I think um with
mutual respect and understanding um I
think that in season one because Alfred
wasn't isn't Bruce's father um he really
they were constantly butting heads and
Bruce was kind of saying you can't tell
me what to do I'm gonna do what I want
to do and they were just constantly not
agreeing on things and because of the
revealing of whatever is down that's
their case I think that really takes
it's a new chapter in their relationship
and they're gonna go through a little
bit of a rocky patch but once they get
through that you're really gonna start
to see him become his mentor and they're
gonna be on the same team and like Shawn
likes the callin operation good guys
operation good guys
Danny for you Danny for you you know
being that we all know where this
eventually ends with a certain cape and
a a certain mask how do you how do you
get the story to keep going to keep
telling us the new a new way of looking
at Gotham a new way of looking at Batman
what are the elements that were
important to you
well I think what I'm understanding
about this as we as we do it is the
villains have lived forever and and
they've been some of the most known
villains in in history I think and and
it's because they don't have those
blocks in our head that teach us how to
be they live outside of that they are
Anarchy they are chaos you know they are
free in that sense and I love their
freedom I think we all do when somebody
really doesn't give a damn they become
incredibly interesting and so this
season is all about the origins of so
many more villains not just what's
happened to all these people and what
they've gone through and what they've
become
but what Gotham can give birth to when
people start to feel power within
themselves and don't feel their urge to
have some petty timid morality they can
be free and that's exciting we want to
take some questions from you guys very
soon so if you have them start lining up
there's microphones set up around the
around the hall you guys have questions
all right to talk to follow up and what
Danny said though let's talk about one
villain in particular Robin it seems
that you have definitely risen oh man
wait what what happened
what's up like right people at yeah
uh what do you think where is he now
from where he was when we started when
he was just like fish's waiter
essentially I mean yeah he he achieved
his his goal he's the king of Gotham
we'll see I mean yeah for the time being
this guy this guy line that that's a
good point I mean you know a key you
know he spent the whole you know first
season you know plotting all of this
laying the groundwork having it finally
achieved it you know he's he's
intelligent he knows that once you reach
the top there's someone right there
ready to take you down so you know he's
prepared to you know fight to stay up
there you know we'll see what happens
uh-huh you know it's never a smooth ride
with with Oswald but uh but yeah he's
he's living large now so yeah it's good
hey guys yes yes Corey could you be the
person to take him down I don't know I
think we should ask them all right would
you have some questions from you guys I
can't see anyone oh my god they have
lights that's amazing hello Hey please
say who your questions for if you can
all right I'm jaded a huge fan of the
show actually first this isn't really a
quick it's a question after first I want
to say I've had a crush on Cameron for
the longest time
thank you for your support of the show
you might Catco blush uh my question is
is for anybody who wants to answer who
is your favorite cast member to work
with anyone oh well mine Steve EADS
without a dime yeah I got Shona ok ok
tango kidding I think as you know what's
interesting about this show is that
every time you get to work when when
Shawn and I got to do something special
last year obviously because working with
Ben is a dream but it's exciting for us
sometimes cuz we were locked in
different worlds where we didn't
interact that every time we got to
interact with each other it was kind of
like on any given day we are all each
other's favorite person to work with
it's a really tight group of people Wow
you don't hear that from a lot of casts
all right so we have that's a very
bright t-shirt you have you could be
seen without the spotlight thank you
very much I'm a huge fan of the show I
just wanted to start off by saying oh hi
question Oh
do we have here a tan of your work hey
how eyes you paint our draw I'm gonna
find you we gotta get a picture of that
yeah I'm gonna find you to Rome and I'm
gonna take you down
see ya I I think that they're telling us
we got to get off the stage thinks we
have a new friend in town ladies and
gentlemen please give it up for the cast
and creative of Gotham
you